don't vote for me it's Wednesday that
means black mirror and I am now on the
third episode of the second season and
that puts me at the Waldo moment this
one was weird I don't just mean like as
a premise as a story I mean for Black
Mirror this one is weird and this one I
it's happened with a couple of episodes
where I I haven't done my review
immediately after watching it I have
instead sort of thought on it and worked
over in my head what is it that I just
watched and usually when I do that it's
because I need more time to digest it
and sort of deal with everything that it
you know sort of brought up within me in
the case of this one I've just been
trying to see figure out or try to
figure out what it is it's actually
doing because there's one of a couple
things going on here either I missed
something which is a distinct
possibility that I am completely open to
and I fully expect they'll be commenters
pointing out if that is in fact the case
but if I didn't then it seems to try and
combine two different ideas that I'm not
sure actually complement each other and
also neither of which feels properly
explored now to a certain extent I kind
of made a complaint a little bit like
this about the season 4 episode called
Archangel but in that one eye I said
that it the episode could have used more
focus on something really specific about
the technology that that episode was
exploring but at the very least this
sort of the two things that I said it
was doing that I kind of wish it had
just focused on one of them at the very
least very much complemented each other
they were inherently about you know more
or less the same thing just slightly you
know
more specific on one or another aspect
of it in this case this seems to be
combining you know sort of concepts of a
creator losing control and ownership of
his own creation at the same time as
sort of looking at the absurdity of I I
was gonna say the absurdity of politics
I'm not sure if it if I could say that
that sounds like over something I guess
the absurdity of the electoral process
and those two ideas don't inherently gel
and I'm not sure that the episode found
a way to mesh them properly which is a
shame because I think it was still doing
some interesting things in both realms
just because they don't kind of buoy
each other both those aspects feel a
little bit underserved and I feel like
if if this was going to be much more
about a creator or an artist finding out
that he is not necessary for the success
of the art that he was the creator for
and you know this sort of something that
was his and getting out of control and
becoming bigger than him it could have
dug that into that a bit more although I
feel like that's something that you know
I've seen done elsewhere often in these
kind of literalized forms I'm not sure I
could say where I've seen it done well
because most of the examples that I can
think of my brain is kind of jumping to
things like cool world or Simone you
know it's an interesting concept that
I've seen explored before I'm not sure
I've seen a good film or show or
anything actually trying to address it
but it's and I'm not sure this does that
well a job of addressing it either so
there's that and then there's you know
we literally have a talking bluebear
running for office and this is being
treated
prising Lee seriously by a surprising
number of people and that I obviously I
can't put myself back in time and know
what that was like to watch at the time
that it aired what I can say is that
living in an era where it feels like
that kind of happened it comes across
basically as pointing out the problem
but not having anything to say about it
and that's not me saying like it needs
to propose a solution or anything is I'm
not sure there is a solution to to that
kind of problem but at the very least I
feel like it should be making a
statement about it besides just kind of
pointing going hey isn't that messed up
and maybe that would have played better
you know back before it feels like this
actually happened and it could have
gotten away with being a bit more you
know prophetic and a forward-thinking
way as opposed to prophetic in hindsight
where it becomes on the one hand kind of
unnerving and not in mephitic didn't hit
me in the funny bone the way that say
national anthem did in this case it was
just like because reality actually went
this way to a certain degree I I look at
this and it feels like something that
was written just this past year and it
would have been considered very on the
nose not particularly subtle doesn't
really have a overall point kind of
satire and I can appreciate the
forward-thinking nosov it for when it
was aired you know predating the 2016
presidential election in the u.s. if he
hadn't already figured out who I was
talking about and you know I don't oh I
really try not to bring my own politics
into into this show if I can help it
unless I feel they're exceptionally
relevant but I think I can't not at the
very least
without getting into too many specifics
of my own political hang-ups or or what
not at the very least please grant me
that 2016 saw someone who was popularly
understood to primarily be at that point
an entertainer and running a campaign
that most people considered to be a joke
and who at the same time still garnered
you know in a degree of support that was
largely dismissed but was highly
significant despite you know this person
skirting all the normal niceties of how
politics are usually run whether you
consider all that to be a good thing or
a bad thing that's kind of objectively
what happened and that just makes
watching this episode just a strange
experience but if I try and remove
myself from the from the prophetic
nature of the whole thing I'm just left
going okay so an artist loses control of
his art so what you know the but the
political process is kind of hollow and
screwed up and a lot of people don't
take it seriously who should so what you
know I just feel like there isn't a
point being made and maybe the problem
is is that usually black mirror it's not
always making up certainly not making
like a huge thematic or or certainly not
political point most of the time but it
is it at the very least usually making
an emotional point you know something
like white bear or the entire history of
you or crocodile or all those things
they are making emotional points this
doesn't feel like it has
this doesn't connect with me
exceptionally in terms of getting me
emotionally and so just that just leaves
me with something that I'm not sure what
its point was which inclines me to think
that it just it didn't hit it hard
enough because like I said I'm just I'm
just left with these two aspects that
don't really complement each other at
least not as not as well as they needed
to and again like I said it is a
distinct possibility that I'm just not
getting something I admire some of the
ideas but just the this is like the one
case because generally this show
executes at a very high level and in
this case I feel like the script needed
another another draft another polish to
refine exactly what it was that it was
doing and so I feel like it was one one
maybe two revisions away from from
really coming together and instead we're
left with something that I can recognize
the potential in the components and I
can recognize sort of aspects and where
they could go but it doesn't feel like
any of them fully arrive anywhere and I
think this is definitely my least
favorite episode of this season it's
probably my least favorite episode of
Black Mirror I've seen to date and
reminder for folks I've now seen all of
season four all of season one I believe
this is the last episode of season two
so I've just got the Christmas special
in season three to get through now but
and this probably is my least favorite
that said it's still not bad
it doesn't quite get there but it's
still well acted it's still dealing with
some interesting concepts and you know
it's trying to look at sort of the
mimetic nature of just how we digests
information and even stuff that is
supposed to be taken seriously I get I
get all that and that's all stuff worth
exploring and again it while it doesn't
quite get there it's not a total failure
it's not like I'm watching it going boy
you didn't even come close to hitting
the point you were trying to make I just
feel like it didn't quite know exactly
what it was targeting and so it's just
it's just a little bit unfocused and
that's a shame because I think you know
speaking as someone you know I hesitate
to call myself a creator because that
seems like lofty and self-important but
I mean I you know I do this I write I
don't have anything published don't ask
but like I enjoy stories of our stories
I enjoy stories about artists and the
relationship they have with their art
that's something I can connect with yet
this one didn't really connect with me
again I I just keep coming back to this
I think it's because I don't think the
episode really knew if it was about that
more than it was about how messed up
politics and the public's relationship
with the political process is so yeah
that's the Waldo moment it just kind of
an odd one I think and I I get the
impression that this is probably one of
the less liked episodes I didn't think
too much of that going in because
metalhead also appeared to be one of the
less liked episodes you know in season
four and I really enjoyed that one so I
didn't take it as a given that this was
going to be a weaker episode but I think
I think it just is there's there's good
building blocks here it's just not it
just doesn't come together I feel like
I've said some variant of that same
thing probably 50 times now so that's
probably the point that I'm just gonna
wrap this thing up so though although
moment what were your thoughts on it
whatever they were drop something down
in the comments let's talk about it do
all that stuff you know what there is to
do support
man patreon if you're feeling generous
like subscribe I got t-shirts I got a
podcast what are links for all this up
is down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]